we live in a fast-moving and challenging
time global energy consumption is rising
at a higher pace than ever in the last
decades the world is hungry for energy
and for growth and at the same time
scientific evidence shows so that if
leave with his strengths unchecked if we
do not cut greenhouse gas emissions
urgently global temperature will rise
dangerous levels and the strain on our
planet's natural resources with man's
unsustainable tackling this paradox
requires the term in police action
that's why the European Union has set as
its top priority to transform our
economy and society and become a cleaner
cleaner and more sustainable place this
is the essence of the European Green
Deal that the Commission will present
tomorrow and an agenda to make Europe
the first climate neutral continent by
2050 the they transition to climate
neutrality will bring positive change
new jobs will be created new value
change will take shape across our
region's innovation will flourish the
European Green Deal will open new
opportunities in all sectors from
Transport to taxation from food to
farming from industry to infrastructure
it will be a growth agenda and agenda
for sustainable competitiveness at the
same time such a radical transformation
may bring real lot of disruption there
are disparities in Europe the starting
points are different the ability to
embrace change is uneven for some
regions some communities moving away
from fossil fuels based economy will
imply
tough choices and costs
at least in the short term I am very
aware of this I come from a small
country that has long relied on fossil
fuels to ensure its precious energy
security and where the transition will
have a serious economic social and
regional consequences consequences that
is why the European Union is committed
to a chess transition to a process that
leaves no one behind and takes care of
its territorial and society real impacts
this is not new for the European Union
with the creation of the single market
or the introduction of the euro we
learnt that when I push for a
wide-ranging ambitious policy we need to
take a broader look at things it is not
sufficient to put on the to put the
right rules and signals in place you
need to make sure that change will work
for all this means that the negative
impacts and are considered and addressed
and that all voices stakeholders local
authorities are hurt either
the Green Deal works for all or it will
not work at all as president ponder Lyon
said here in Madrid we can promise HS
transition because we have two
presidents to look towards as a basis
and an inspiration
they are the Covenant of Mayors and the
platform for core regions in transition
the European Commission has supported
the Covenant of Mayors for climate and
energy since its creation on in 2008 in
the past 10 years over 9,000 European
cities have signed up to the covenant
over two-thirds of the new population
now live in the government city what is
even more impressive are the results
obtained by cities applying to covenant
of mayors recipes Danish
objective was to cut emissions by 20% by
2020 this objective was surpassed as
cities outperformed their member states
in reduce in reducing emissions on
average Caron cities will reduce their
emissions close to 30% by the 2020 we
are all witnessing these achievements
right now Madrid our host city made
significant progress on emissions and
air quality by setting up a low emission
zone in this city centre future trends
are also positive many of command
signatories have already upgraded their
commitments to reach a 40% cut in
emissions by 2030 a pool of leading
cities already envisioned in Mission sir
climbing to 20 by 2050 and some of them
even earlier the success story has
spread beyond geo borders in cooperation
with our us partners Bloomberg
philanthropies we extended the covenant
to the rest of the world the global
covenant of mayors now covers 10,000
cities worldwide second the European
Commission has developed since 2017
targeted and well-functioning support
for the use coal regions in that in
their transition to a low-carbon economy
in AU nearly 200,000 people are directly
employed in this coal sector poor if you
had peat and oil shale and other solid
fossil fuels with a similar profile and
fate the purpose of this program is to
help these communities diversify their
economies and launch new future-proof
activities after two years of
implementation of the coal in transition
program progress is already measurable
we develop transition decisions low
crease and soon also in Romanian
Slovenia we also helped coal regions in
Poland Czech Republic and Slovakia to
reallocate EU funding to
just transition projects overall more
than 400 million euros of EU funds were
reprogrammed we are not just focusing on
the transition away from coal pastes
power systems the clean energy for EU
Islands program helps geographically
isolated or sparsely populated
territories that without extra support
will not be able to participate in the
energy transition to be energy decision
to their benefit other people our work
on energy power is also crucial up to 50
million people in Europe are not able to
properly heat their homes in 2017 the
European Commission set up an energy
poverty observatory we are now
developing guidance to support Member
States regional and local authorities to
tackle this problem at the most adequate
level this is the basis of which we will
build our ambitious and our ambitions
for a just fair climate transition that
works for all the cornerstone will be
the just transition fund designed to
help those regions which will have to
take a bigger step and move away from
urban intensive and coal based
production the fund will help the
region's invest in the diversification
antique urbanization of their economies
in retraining workers or promoting new
economic activities the fund will be
part of Prada mechanism it will leverage
public and private money including with
the help of the European Investment Bank
furthermore we will use the next you
budget and every other tool in our
disposal to ensure that necessary
investment to steer the transition and
ensure it remains fair our tonne your
funds and public subsidies will not be
enough to deliver a successful
transition private investments will be
Kien effectively implementing the
transition that's why we will deliver a
sustainable Europe investment plan which
will support 1 trillion euros of
investment over the next decade revenues
from the sale of emissions allowances in
the ETS scheme will be used to
accelerate the transition with a new
innovation and modernization fund the
European Investment Bank will become a
climate bank supporting your efforts by
adopting its lending policy to the
challenges of today and tomorrow the
European Green Deal cannot be a top-down
agenda it will not succeed if we fail to
involve citizens those whose lives will
be directly impacted the company that
the European Green Deal process the
European Commission will launch a
climate pact which will bring together
regions cities businesses and citizens
together we will design new commitments
aim at changing individual and
collective behaviors and reinforce
ownership of the transition process
people must remain a center stage the EU
has decided to lead the way to lead the
way and set their strategic vision for
becoming the first climate neutral
continent by 2050 to make this happen we
will need all levels of government to
cooperate and deliver in step member
states hold the key of the national
energy and climate policy regions are
best placed to define priorities as
regards three economic development and
how best diversify and key Karma's
regional value chain cities are
implementing concrete measurable changes
in the daily life of Europeans from
local transport to renovation of public
schools and social housing you are the
partners and the European Commission
will stand
member states regions and cities in any
way we can that's why we believe that
this session is one of the most
important of the our EU energy days we
can win the climate neutrality change if
we work hand in hand I'm looking forward
to your ideas and proposals to start
this journey together towards a cleaner
cleaner and more resilient society
and doing this together thank you
[Applause]